madame Blanchette Vézina bonsoir
bonsoir alors faisons le point d'abord
ça m'intrigue un peu qu'est-ce que
Québec êtes-vous au courant qu'est-ce
que Québec a demandé aux Forces armées
canadiennes comme aide est-ce que c'est
une aide officiel
en fait c'est mon collègue François
renardel on a demandé l'aide de l'armée
dans différentes sphères il y a certains
que la situation en ce moment c'est une
situation qui est exceptionnelle
d'ailleurs je tiens à souligner le
travail qui est fait sur le terrain par
nos équipes de la soft feu les équipes
du ministère également l'ensemble des
gens qui collaborent puis aussi les
citoyens qui ont qui ont répondu qu'ils
répondent de positivement en fait qu'on
demande et qu'on a interdit l'accès au
temps public dans plusieurs secteurs du
Québec pour permettre que le travail des
pompiers puissent se faire des équipes
d'urgence donc les choses se passent
bien mais donc on a quand même besoin
parce qu'il y a plus de 109 feux donc
toutes sans feux qui sont actifs en ce
moment sur plusieurs territoires du
Québec à couvrir donc on a demandé de
l'aide de certains pays et notamment de
l'armée canadienne mais quel est de
l'armée qu'est-ce qu'on veut de l'armée
du matériel
en termes de logistique bien sûr de
déploiement et comment qu'on se entre
provinces on s'entraide lorsque des
interventions à faire en feu de forêt
mais là la situation elle est vécue dans
plusieurs provinces canadiennes donc on
va demander c'est interventions cette
taille de terrain tactique à l'armée
pour avoir une plus grande force de
déploiement bon ok on y reviendra pour
pour ce qui est de vous de votre
juridiction là vous en avez vous avez
fait référence à ça vous avez interdit
on va voir la carte dans cette région
très
particulière très précise interdiction
d'accès là on parle pas d'interdiction
de feu va sans dire mais d'interdiction
d'accès racontez-moi qu'est-ce qui a
justifié le choix de ces 7 endroits que
l'on voit en rouge
en fait il est arrivé hier situation des
orages ont éclaté dans plusieurs régions
du Québec avec des éclairs qui ont
allumé certains foyers plusieurs foyers
d'incendie en même temps donc la seule
feufure et les gens sur le terrain ont
priorisé des secteurs priorisés pour
bien sûr s'assurer de la sécurité des
gens des municipalités des
infrastructures ce qui fait que certains
secteurs il y a des feux qui sont actifs
mais sur lesquels on ne fait pas
d'intervention donc on veut s'assurer
que les citoyens ne se mettent pas dans
une situation dangereuse en allant dans
des secteurs où il peut y avoir des feux
qu'on ne suit pas en ce moment puisqu'on
comme on voulait mentionner en priorise
une vingtaine quinzaine de feux selon
selon le niveau de de dangerosité ou
d'atteindre à des infrastructures
essentielles donc on demande la
collaboration des gens il y a des gens
sur le terrain aussi du ministère de la
Sécurité publique la SQ coordonne le
l'ensemble des fermetures de tronçons et
de chemin pour s'assurer donc les gens
ne se mettent pas dans des situations
dangereuses pour le week-end où on
aurait peut-être voulu aller en forêt
pour pour la pêche la chasse mais
de tous ok mais sur le terrain est-ce
que ça va être clairement identifié
qu'on a dans une zone où on peut pas
aller
il y a des gens sur le terrain
directement qui sont déployés sur les
routes bien sûr les gens qui ont des
beaux de villégiature dans les terres
publics pour l'instant on demande aux
gens de ne pas aller sur leur dans leur
chalet il y a une ligne qui a été mise
en place le 1 8 7 7 6 4 4 5 4 5 si les
gens veulent vérifier est-ce que leur
secteurs sont visés on peut appeler à ce
numéro qui est important de respecter
ces mesures pour s'assurer de ne pas un
mètre sa vie en danger mais aussi de
permettre que le travail des pompiers
puisse se faire
8/7 vous avez dit 6 qu'on va aller on va
essayer de l'inscrire à l'écran après 6
4 5 4 5 6 4 4
feux de forêt du gouvernement du Québec
sur québec.ca que les gens peuvent aller
consulter c'est soit avoir de
l'information plus précise les régions
qui sont visées on parle d'habitivité
médicament de leur entier de Lanaudière
Saguenay-Lac-Saint-Jean côte nord nord
du Québec bien sûr dans la région de
cette île vous comprendrez également que
ces secteurs donc on demande aux gens de
ne pas aller en forêt du tout en plus
des interdictions de feu qui sont qui
vise ensemble du Québec l'industrie
forestière depuis quand ils ont eu hors
de ne plus
s'activer en forêt au Québec
en début de semaine on a déjà demandé à
l'industrie forestière de ne pas
retourner faire des travaux forestiers
puisque ça c'est une source potentielle
de feu avec les équipements la
machinerie peut y avoir des états selles
on se doutait avec le temps qui était
très chaud il peut y avoir des risques
mais la source principale des feux en ce
moment c'est l'orage qui s'est déclenché
sur plusieurs régions du Québec hier et
qui a allumé plusieurs fois
intéressantes
très bien merci beaucoup d'avoir été en
direct madame Blanchet de Vésinet je
rappelle que Québec que vous avez
demandé l'aide des Forces canadiennes ce
n'est pas encore clair pour moi comment
pourrais-je faire un déploiement puis à
quel moment mais
on va on va essayer de d'en savoir
davantage merci beaucoup de nous avoir
parlé par ailleurs
au revoir